[Musique]
l'abs et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue à
24,60 hors série il a chanté la nature
l'amour le québec je dis go est un
orfèvre des mots
aujourd'hui quel temps fait-il sur le
québec de gilles vigneault
à l'heure des changements climatiques de
l'immigration de l'appropriation
culturelle et du populisme ce soir une
réflexion avec le grand gilles vigneault
nous sommes allés à sa rencontre
à
gilles vigneault bonjour bonjour à vous
faire pour vous rencontrer venir chez
vous dans un studio un atelier ils me
jugent sur le boulevard rené lévesque
ça résume un peu le temps l'espace où
vous êtes aussi oui moment où vous
sortez ce coffret le temps qu'il fait
sur mon pays où est important de parler
du temps qu'il fait sourire oui sur
l'hiver surtout après les rois
ouais à noter le temps fait-il sur votre
pays il fait à l'extérieur du studio où
nous sommes il fait un temps raisonnable
pour l'hiver mais quand même le temps
qu'il fait sur mon pays est extrêmement
extrêmement changé dans bien des corps
et ce dans bien des parties de la terre
à cause des changements climatiques et
je ne suis pas un sceptique qui m'a tout
sceptiques ou pas du tout je je suis un
climat tout hélas trop sûr du fait qu'
on est en train de massacrer un vaisseau
spatial absolument extraordinaire un
vaisseau spatial qu'on a depuis le début
et qu'on a commencé à massacrer très tôt
d'ailleurs mais sans le savoir
aujourd'hui on le massacre et on est
organisée avec la technologie pour
savoir ce qu'on est en train de faire et
on continue de le faire et ce qui me
scandalise
ce qui m'inquiète c'est c'est qu'on
continue à chercher dans l'univers une
terre sur laquelle on pourrait aller
faire les mêmes dégâts les mêmes
massacre
et c'est d'une naïveté de découvrir ces
naïfs en ce que on n'a pas trouvé encore
les moteurs qui nous conduirait à la
vitesse de la lumière par exemple
quelques pas où on pourrait recommencer
inferno bêtise humaine parce que la
bêtise humaine
vous l'avez dénoncer très tôt dans votre
parcours de poètes et les premières dès
les premières chansons vous sentez la
nature comment cette destruction aussi
déjà commencé à la vérité à en parler en
60 et six dans une chanson qui
s'appelait c'est le temps d'écouter la
rivière et quand je suis arrivé à la
maison il ya un enfant qui m'a raconté
qu'il avait eu un devoir sur l'écologie
l'écologie je n'avais pas entendu le mot
encore et j'ai dit mais je viens parler
de sow puis là après ça que je me suis
entêté à en reparler toutes les voix que
l'occasion se présente je pense à des
150 des tourterelles je pense à des
chansons que des poèmes des comptes
gaia le temps qu'il ferait tant qu'il
fait sur mon pays mais j'ai mal à la
terre
la chanson qui disait c'est le temps
d'écouter la lumière s'éteint d'écouter
ce que la rivière arnould dire c'est le
temps d'écouter ceux qui parlent de
sorte c'est le temps d'écouter les
savons les gens les plus savants sont
aujourd'hui considérés par le président
des états unis comme des ignorants
c'est quand même inquiétant c'est un
président qui allait pouvoir de
déclencher pas vraiment mais une guerre
nucléaire
car car dans les mains des objets
extrêmement inquiétant extrêmement
dangereux et qui évidemment qui serait
contredit immédiatement par son
état-major
mais il reste que c'est depuis 45
on a une terre en danger deux cents
alors on essaye par toutes sortes de
moyens de faire donner un petit moment
de réflexion avec l'humilité qui est pas
courant dans notre métier mais avec
l'humilité est toujours consciente quand
même du fait que avec des petits moyens
on peut faire de grandes grandes choses
et des choses très important beaucoup
plus important que prévu une allumette
dans la paille déclenché un incendie
californien est donc avec quelques monde
des fois il y a quelqu'un qui fera une
thèse et demain la thèse sera défendue
et ça va faire un savant qui dit
attention les glaciers sont en train de
fond est ce que donc ça nous place dans
une dans une situation de grande
inquiétude vous êtes inquiet vous portez
s'attaquer dessus de la et aussi on ne
comprend pas
nous humains oui ce qu'on est en train
de faire tous les poètes vos mots on
partait quand même mais on en compte
notre journal et les grands les grands
thèmes de 2,2 la démarche humaine sont
le sexe l'argent le pouvoir et nous
sommes a conduit par sa menée par la
recherche de pouvoir l'argent qui
conduit au pouvoir et nous nous sommes
constamment les les robots de deux notes
rians nous sommes inquiétant et en même
temps en même temps nous nous avons d un
esprit absolument contradictoire parce
que il ya des jeunes qui sont en train
de trouver des solutions
ils n'ont besoin que de l'argent des
gros milliardaire
de la tête pour résoudre les problèmes
que les gros milliardaire de la terre
ont créé avec leur industrie avec leur
l'eure l'eure l'eure pétrole on extrait
du pétrole comme si c'était la la la
panacée universelle alors qu' il y a
maintenant on a encore le levant et et
le soleil qu'on n'a pas fini d'exploiter
coin qu'on commence tout juste à deviner
alors on à ses contradictions alors moi
j'ai comme un espoir dans le fait que la
jeunesse est informé aujourd'hui
l'information se lavait aujourd'hui
c'est le véritable moulin en étage vous
exercés par des coudes et j'ai je vous
demandais dans ses 60 ans d'écriture de
poèmes et de chansons
au fond qu'est ce qui a changé ce qui a
changé le plus c'est qu'on commence à
s'informer c'est on commence à voir une
curiosité en rapport avec ce vaisseau
spatial klein foudroyé au début je
trouve que l'humanité est en train de
s'instruire l'humanité vont instruire
par ses enfants ce sont les enfants qui
vont nous avertir et essayer de corriger
nos bêtises et et et nous les dire nous
les réciter en france c'est certain
cette certitude vous l'apprenez parce
que c'est tellement confiance aux
enfants vous avez écrit pour les enfants
vous alles est allé à la rencontre des
enfants et vous misez donc sur cette
enfance un peu pour une certaine
mortalité ou sur toujours on essaye
c'est comme le gars qui dit oui je sais
que tout le monde au mauvais mais j'ai
cru que pour moi
il me semble que c'est le temps c'est le
temps d'écouter la rivière c'est le
temps c'est le temps d'écouter
pour le temps qu'il reste de l'erdre en
l'air tant qu'il reste de nombreux lots
[Musique]
alors on parlait de ce pays de temps
qu'il fait sur ce pays
gilles vigneault dans vous publié
aujourd'hui pour chansons de jeunesse
qui vous ont propulsé dans un petit
arrière est presque instantanée vous qui
êtes venus semble-t-il à la chanson
comme interprète entre caux presque par
hasard et c'est à cette première époque
que vous avez écrit à la fois mon pays
et aussi les gens de mon pays dans
lesquels déjà vous abordiez des
questions sur cette approche tout
l'hiver votre pays
c'est en tout une allégorie métaphore
mais l'importance de l'autre
l'importance de s'ouvrir à l'autre je
dis aux gens de la terre que ma maison
c'est votre maison le temps et l'espace
c'était à l'époque je suis pas peut-être
pas vraiment rendu compte mais c'était
plus grave à dire que je ne l'escomptais
que je ne jouis santé il me semblait que
c'est important ça devait être dit comme
ça à peu près mais je t'es pas content
et j'ai essayé toute ma vie de le dire
autrement parce qu'on a fait on essaye
de refaire la chanson qu'on n'est pas
contents d'avoir vraiment fignoler pour
en terminer pour que les gens là
comprennent et agissent d'après ensuite
quand vous êtes tous les humains sont de
ma race il ya c'est comme si on
n'entendait pas ça maintenant quand on
voit les flux migratoires quand on voit
là la volonté de construire un mur on ne
sait jamais mais qu'ils frappent à la
porte
non on ne sait jamais ce qu'il nous
apporte entre ses quatre murs de glace
je mets mon temps et mon espace à
préparer le faire à plein
pour les jurés de la visant car les
humains sens de ma race
au québec c'est une très belle occasion
de dire au monde
de toute façon vous allez venir
c'est ici qu'il y a de la place il y à
la plage pour non seulement vous de pied
mais votre tête et tout le corps et il
ya de la place pour vous faire un lieu
de vie sur la terre c'est ici qu'il ya
de la place
ils ne savent maintenant avec
l'information
il sait bien qu'il le sable en fait si
on était dans la même position
on sera heureux de savoir et on serait
heureux d'y venir est ce qu'on n'ouvre
assez grand les portes ou en effet remet
trop les portes on ouvre les portes dans
la mesure où on est capable de gérer la
visite sans disparaître
ouais parce qu'on peut ouvrir les portes
ou point de disparaître soi-même et
celui qui a ouvert la porte
la porte lui appartenait un jour il
devra céder la place de portier
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a peur de l'eau on
a peur de l'autre parce que au fond et
c'est une très très intéressante
question je pense qu'on a peur de l'eau
parce qu'on a peur de soi parce qu'on se
connaît un peu et on sait à quel point
on peut être un conséquent et
imprévisible on sait de l'intérieur à
quel point on peut se tromper et on a
peur que que l'autre
elle perd lui aussi
les gens de mon pays ce sens gens de
parole
les gens de causerie qui parle pour
s'entendre
le bourreau parler il faut les écouter
c'est parfois vérité et c'est parfois
mon changent mais la plupart du temps
c'est le bonheur qui dit comme il
s'était fait une période pour vous que
s'inscrivait beaucoup dans le
nationalisme québécoise à l'amour était
d'abord un pays dans un certain
patriotisme ou certainement mais c'était
pas dans votre esprit irréconciliable
avec l'ouverture aux autres santé par
l'ex vous n'avez pas d'exclusion
pas du tout jeudi jeudi dans plusieurs
chansons pour être chez soi pour dire
welcome way we est temps qu'on ait poche
vraiment chez soi on est au nom n'a pas
l'autorité et monsieur legault est en
train d'en faire l'expérience
et que le canada avoir décidé combien on
peut accueillir d'étrangers et ça va
arriver
contrairement à ce qu'on va décider au
québec et monsieur legault est en train
d'apprendre que le canada est le maître
de tout ça est sale
mais chez le goût est un vieux
nationaliste il n'est peut-être pas si
vieux il s'est peut-être quelqu'un qui a
gardé son ancien la lys mme plus jeune
con le sale con c'est vous les faites
confiance
ouais je je fais confiance
moi je fais confiance bon je ne fais pas
confiance à monsieur le goût avant
l'élection je serais très très sincère
très franc mais je fais confiance je
fais confiance dans l'humanité fait
confiance à l'homme qui naît et au
nationalisme qu'il a été qu'ils ont
nationalisé qu'il a été et qu'il ne
revient de temps en temps qu'on va le
voir on veut redevenir
je fais confiance ça va on appelle ça la
fois on y vient forcément de quoi
compare on y vient croire dans l'autre
la fois ça commence comme ça la foi
c'est d'abord horizontales ont fait
confiance dans les êtres qui nous
entoure et les humains qu'on rencontre
et après ça si quelqu'un veut faire un
cercle de ceux là et construire une fois
dans celui de plus que moi que je
m'efforce d'être celle d'être flatteur
pour un être soi disant infinie en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on a dit longtemps le
beau et beaucoup quand on quand on pense
à un savant un philosophe qui a dit que
à force de nommer quelques choses ont
fini par la faire exister c'est
intéressant est le dieu en question doit
être flatté parce que on a essayé de le
nommer pendant toute l'humanité toute
l'histoire de l'humanité on a essayé de
lui trouver un nom et un moment donné
tellement mal réussi que l'on la nommer
l'innommable
on a on a vécu des événements en sondant
en son nom inhumain et nommément
moi je dis avec les bts que les hommes
ont fait en son nom il a le devoir
d'exister est un devoir tout ça quand
même d'autant vous quand même coup évité
si on n'a pas de doute
la foi n'est pas sûr mais est ce que
parce que c'est le meilleur
ces deux meilleurs vieux camarade le
plus vieux camarade de de la foi est ce
que la foi c'est ce qui rend serait et
heureux au moment où on célèbre ses 90
par exemple savant un tout petit peu
plus serein peut-être mais ça ne rend
pas heureux
tant que ça ne rend pas beaucoup
d'autres m'ont heureux si on est heureux
tout seul c'est un malheur comme un an
l'idéal du bonheur existe partout mais
en revenant au temps qu'il fait sur
votre pays à mon pays aux gens du pays à
cette ouverture à l'autre il reste que
ça a été entendu depuis 50 ans 60 ans
comme un chant patriotique mais oui oui
dont un pays rêvé mais le pays a évolué
dans votre coeur dans votre tête
j'imagine est-ce que après deux
référendums
l'apd est la mise à l'écart de cette
idée est ce que vous êtes un homme déçu
de ne pas avoir réalisé votre rêve du
pays réel comme tous ceux qui ont eu ce
rêve et qui ont été déçus il est bien
sûr mais je ne suis pas que déçu je suis
un déçu espérant c'est à dire c'est à
dire que j'ai confiance dans j'ai foi
dans la jeunesse qui va reprendre dans
qui vont reprendre comme on se rend beau
mais leurs flambeaux qui vont trouver un
flambeau et qui vont le reprendre mais
le tenir au mais pour d'autres raisons
que nous autres nous un environnement
justement
un volet environnement et modération
d'autres raisons et voilà être des
raisons qui vont s'appliquer à la terre
entière et pas seulement au québec parce
que dans la chanson vivre debout au fond
vous
ouvrez les portes aussi mais vous êtes
quand même parce que il ya quand même
péril en la demeure
il ya péril en la demeure c'est une
alliance et cuir merci beaucoup de
mentionner l'expression c'est que ya
péril en la demeure c'est une très
vieille expression de la langue
française
ben quelques cercles qui dit il y as
péril en demeurant pareil en demeurant
le même on ne voulons rien changé c'est
là qu'il ya perret on le fait de
demeurer ce qu'on est
il y as péril dans le refus de changer
soi même de changer l'intérieur de soi
même c'est là qu'il ya pérenne et je ne
vais pas expliquer dans la chanson parce
que c'était très long et il arrivait pas
vous êtes ne pourra toujours se se plier
à toutes les exigences d'une chance
constat quand même à travers ses
chansons et beaucoup d'autres
l'inquiétude face à la langue une grande
inquiétude est une grande équipe avec ce
qu'on vit même en ontario en ce moment
où ailleurs au canada
ouais ça a été une belle un beau sursaut
l'ontario et je considère que moi
en entendant ce que partout où le
français est en danger il faut le
secourir il est il ici en ce moment il
est en danger au québec on sait comment
on sait pourquoi et les belles
technologies qui nous apprennent qu'ils
nous donnent beaucoup d'informations il
faut de la formation avant pour
accueillir l'information et s'en servir
convenablement il faut d'abord de la
formation la formation ça vient pas
l'instruction les connaissances
la lecture l'éducation ça vient partout
sa part par tout ce que monsieur trompe
semble ignoré et méprisé en même temps
alors l'ignorance qui méprise la
connaissance c'est vieux comme le monde
parce que elle l'a craint
bien
être chez soi permet d'accueillir
l'étranger
mais qu'il y à toujours péril on à
demain
vivre
baby doc
vous qui avez été professeur vous êtes à
travers la poésie si vous êtes un grand
pédagogue non comment vous décririez
vous très mal je me décris très mal g
j'ai été deux heures sans doute
s'employer philosophe plage le wat et
des grands comptes
ce sont tous des compliments qui nous
vont droit au coeur
droit à la tête ça fait exploser parce
que je ne suis pas tout ça je suis un
petit peu de tout ça parce que je
m'intéresse beaucoup à tout ça tout ça
l'information à l'information et là où
je vous allez me demander
peut-être ou est-ce que vous commencez
le plus d'informations et bien c'est en
moi même ça ça a l'air prétentieux
pas du tout c'est ça au moi même lorsque
je suis en recueillement dans un lieu
silencieux comme une église par exemple
qui a des lieux qui ont l'habitude de
silence où une salle dans laquelle j'ai
travaillé mais qui viennent qui n'a
aucun spectateur le thé à arriver dans
un théâtre comme or le lin bien arriver
dans un tailleur à paris à paris l
arrivée d'ing comme bobino dans ses
vieilles salles on sent que la salle a
beaucoup entendu la salle où c'est par
coeur avant qu'on ouvre la bouche et la
salle n'a pas peur de nous mais est on
n'a pas peur de la salle parce qu'il ya
eu beaucoup d'humains qui sont passés là
il restait beaucoup d'humain dans les
murs et ces choses là se sentent quand
on est dans un lieu qui a l'habitude de
pratiquer le silence et là on appelle ça
du recueillement se re cueillir ce
cueillir de nouveau donc je vais
chercher au fond de moi ce que j'ai
acquis le
cochez acquis et je travaille avec ça et
il m'est arrivé de découvrir le thème
d'une chanson importants comme j'ai mal
à la terre l'uranium dans l'église
assis tout seul dans l'église pendant la
messe non pas pendant les veufs non plus
que j'ai pratiqué d'entente mais il
m'est arrivé de trouver le thème d'une
chanson ou le thème d'un compte d'un
assis tout seul dans l'église
des fois quand on est à l'étranger assis
avec ma femme à 10 ans on va elle aussi
bien à l'église avec moi et on va pas à
l'église pour prier pour demander les i
nous nous font une belle sont là dessus
les genoux il croit aux grands esprits
les genoux ne demandez pas n'avaient pas
de prières et les peuples
ces peuples en général ne met pas de
prière qui demandent ils avaient des
prières qui remerciait de nous avoir
octroyé ce que j'appelle ce merveilleux
vaisseau spatial moi aujourd'hui est de
nous avoir donné ça on partage et il
considérait que toute la nature est un
cadeau c'est pourquoi on les voyait à
battre une belle pour continuer à angers
à nourrir leurs enfants
mais avant il parlait longuement à la
belle en lui disant pourquoi jeter a
battu tu ton âme va passer dans la
vienne parce qu'il croyait à la aussi
donc c'était des croyants
au delà du mot et les et nous remercier
lors dieu le grand esprit j'ai eu
l'occasion d'écrire avec bruno fecteau
une messe dans laquelle bruno a eu
l'idée géniale me dis pourquoi au lieu
de médecins en latin le latin que tu
veux mettre là-dedans par respect pour
ce qui s'est passé on met le poisson en
innu aucun idée formidable et on a fait
traduire le latin en innu et c'était la
première fois que les et nous à
natashquan wire entendait séchant là
dans leur langue
l'as cannes a t il pouvait s'adresser à
leurs grands esprits jack monoloy et
nadine blanche jack monoloy y était
indien il la voyait tous les jours mais
les parents ne savaient rien de nommer
clairement un gant tous les boulots sans
appel
la motion était belle
pascal natashquan vous êtes près des
autochtones des premières nations
vous avez écrit une chanson
bouleversante jack monoloy et c'est dans
vos premières chansons à ouidah mariusz
o oui tu es pour un blanc et aujourd'hui
on a eu plus récemment cette crise avec
d'appropriation culturel ouais j'avais
peur que vous me parliez non non non non
j'étais sûre que hélène barral puis et
je souhaitais aussi parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour robert lepage
qui est un excellent auteur un terrible
metteur en scène est un homme de terrain
censé qui a dit entre autres et me fait
plaisir de le citer ici c'est ce n'est
pas mon âme ou là mais le terrain c'est
la tentative de devenir un peu l'autre
de jouer son rôle et d'apprendre de
l'autre ce qu'il est et d'apprendre de
soi même la compassion envers l'eau
comment apprendre la compassion
si on n'essaye pas de devenir l'autre
les algonquins une très belle manière de
dire ça avant de parler de son voisin il
faut avoir marché six jours dans ses
mocassins
c'est d'une beauté est une simplicité
on est en train de se dire oui on peut
parler de l'autre il faut en parler avec
beaucoup de politesse et aujourd'hui
avec beaucoup de prudence
c'est vrai mais c'est très complexe
parce que en même temps on dit
créé et fait quelque chose et en même
temps on dit faites attention les allées
déplaire vous allez avoir une
controverse vous allez suscite alors le
résultat risque beaucoup d'être temps de
réflexion que moins d'offres et
peut-être une question de censure
l'autocensure moins d'offres et est par
définition c'est ce qui va donner
l'autocensure
vous avez déjà été vous avez vous déjà
été censurée we do montferrand de cul ce
cas vous aimera van wijmeersch ensemble
via c'était pas pour les bonnes raisons
ce n'était pas pour les bonnes raisons
c'était pour la raison du mollah moyens
qu mon père disait ça choix incurable
dans le cas nous et il s'est jamais
considéré comme quelqu'un qui méritait
pas les prières des dames de 7 ans on a
parlé du vent de la pluie du notable
j'ai dit je dis moi comment que tu es
devenu aussi grand
venu j ai dit malgré le danger dans
l'autre sens
je veux dix ans vraiment tout naïvement
venant de natashquan le support du cap
diamant
je trouvais que ça faisait un jeu ayant
un peu puis et puis dans l'autre salle
orange prouver que sa grande salle à
chaud et j'ai trouvé un disque un petit
10 45 au que j'ai encore qui venait de
la discothèque de radio canada sur
lequel il ya un 1 très serrée y est
c'est écrit attention le mot est
pourtant les mots sont si importants
n'est ce pas cet amour des mots dû jouer
avec les mots vous continuez décrire
avec des mots et c'est en revanche il as
well as vous avez en commun
vous avez est-ce que vous avez vous
n'avez pas faire un dictionnaire de
monosilane oui j'ai donné des cours ici
même à des jeunes cède 1,8 neuf
personnes des jeunes au des auteurs
compositeurs et j'ai donné des cours de
mon aussi là bas parce que le
monosyllabes isme permet de devoir au
creux depuis la nuit la lune ce fruit de
haut qui lui bon ça nous permet de
constater que par exemple les mots d'une
seule syllabe sont souvent des résumés
de toute une langue vous commencez à
regarder le le fameux poème de gendrey
c'est gai c'est un poème qui
l'a écrit à propos d'un jeune fille très
très jeune fille est morte et il la voit
sur son cher et il écrit fort belles
ailes d'or sort frêle quel mot rose
claude la brise la prise
c'est un saut n'est parfait et cela
traduit l'émotion du poète trezeguet
face à une mort si jeune c'est beau
c'est triste
cet émouvant à la fois et c'est en 14
mois et je me suis mis à me demander si
on peut créer une chanson comme ça j'en
ai écrit trois ou quatre comme ça dans
laquelle une chanson dans la nuit
d'amour dans laquelle j'utilise deux
mondes deux syllabes ya pas excès tout
ça pour parler du mono silane mais pour
parle portée surtout que dans les mots
la mort avi le froid le chaud le vrai le
faux
dieu le ciel le lieu le vieux est jetée
là on trouve toutes sortes de choses et
on trouve la vie véritable l'essentiel
l'essentiel dans la nuit des mondes j'ai
dit de la vie
de l'âme et du corps de lui l'homme tu
es tu nous
de l'air et de l'eau de tous ceux qui
crient mais si peu de vous mais si peu
de vous
[Musique]
j'ai pour toi un lac quelque part au
monde un bol à tout bleu
il ya toujours urgence ah oui oui je
suis encore trouvé la bonne formule la
bonne chanson
bonne chance est ce que vous avez écrit
parce que pour les québécois est bon
même ça fait le tour du monde histoire
de mon pays c'est devenu un hymne
mais est ce que vous avez écrit la
chanson malgré d'avoir écrit plus 400
avez vous écrit la chanson que vous avez
toujours rêvé de nous louer l'intention
d'écrire
ah ouais oui oui oui j'ai toujours
d'argent en effet gelé tête et chrétiens
il ya trois jours parce que j'en ai fini
je viens d'en finir une mais je suis
toujours à l'ouvragé
vous avez publié vie le disque fait le
disque vivre debout
vous avez dit on a 30 ans on a beau
écrire pendant 30 ans 40 ans 50 ans 60
ans on fait toujours les mêmes chansons
pour les mêmes raisons est ce que c'est
vrai c'est vrai avant c'était à mon avis
c'est toujours les mêmes chansons qu'on
essaye de reprendre pour un fait de
retravailler
on va pas sur l'ancien texte ou rien
on va en daim et on essaye de trouver
quelque chose de nouveau et on écrit et
même beaucoup la même chanson et on a
los on a constamment le sentiment
d'avoir raté son coup de n'avoir pas dit
ce qu'il fallait
ni comme il fallait le dire et et on
recommence
et vous avez toujours cette urgence là
on a parlé de la fois tout à l'heure oui
parlant de la fois c'est quelque chose
qui vous êtes geek qui vous inspirent
qui vous motive qui vous permet de vivre
debout cd certaine manière oui oui ce la
fois à sauver mes parents de la folie
mes parents qui ont perdu six enfants en
bas âge tout jeune
jusqu'à un jeune homme de neuf ans donc
frères ils vont et mon père a souvent
dit c'est ta mère qui m'a sauvée avec
ses prières parce que il avait pensé à
mettre fin à ces douleurs
puis il revenait toujours du bois de
très loin avec de la fourrure des
lièvres de quoi manger paix et et
remercier ma mère chaque fois d'avoir
prié et je me rappelle une chose très
curieuse un jeté à j'étais à l'église
avec mon père il mon père j'avais 5 ans
et mon père m'a emmené dit je veux
l'emmener voir le petit jésus de la
crèche et eddy toi tu voyais demandé
dans cinq ans tu voyais demandé que papa
trouve de l' ouvrage puis lei
de quoi nous faire vivre
le temps était tout le temps tu es jeune
comme moi j'avais été demandé au petit
jus de la crèche avec une sincérité dans
25 ans est une croyance que c'était
passé de mon père me disait je faisais
fois mon père mon père me disait que
j'étais capable
j'ai demandé au petit jésus de nous
procurer de quoi vivent pendant tous
d'un coffret à natashquan avec mon père
je savais pas combien teint est comme
mon père réussit à nous faire vivre bien
un certain moment d'année jeudi d'un
coup dans ces têtes rasées
mais mes prières et est mauvaise et vers
l'âge de 12 13 ans sama ça m'a fait
croire ça me fait croire en moi en ce
que je pouvais faire
et puis ensuite ça m'a fait croire en la
prière la prière c'est une bouteille
avec un message de dunks on en voit la
mer et on sait qu'on ne reverra jamais
mais quelques le trouveront peut-être
est en ce moment en a un et des chansons
des poèmes c'est comme des bouteilles à
la mer aussi sa gamme des centaines de
poèmes des chansons avec cette urgence
d'écrire est que oui et des fois où on a
on a on a quelqu'un qui vient nous dire
tel point
moi ça m'a permis de d'entrer en
relation avec ma femme et on est encore
ensemble et j'étais matches de rang et
ou unetelle poèmes main remis de la mort
d'un ami ou tel poème c'est à après 60
ans d'écriture
il nous vient des messages comme ça des
merveille des merveilles d étonnement de
grand étonnement et des consolations je
peux percevoir bien évident mais vous
pensez que vos foyers vos chansons
rennes telle importance dans la vie dans
la culture et dans le monde
sans ce plan personnel que politique
aussi oui ouais mon appréhension après
maintenant parce que toujours dans ce
petit bilan vous dis je vais l'aborder
rapidement avec la fois s'impose en plus
question de la mort quand je lis tout ce
que vous avez dit écrit là-dessus vous
dites à ces jeunes auteurs compositeurs
qui viennent travailler avec vous dans
ce lieu si vous ne parlez pas de la mort
vous n'avez rien dit oui et ça pourquoi
c'est important d'en parler
et est ce que ça vous fait pas peur et
c'est pas pour la pour conjurer la peur
non c'est simplement pour apprivoiser la
mort j'ai dit ça dans une chanson un
moment donné chacun fin seul dans sa
chanson puis on fait des choses j'en ai
pour apprivoiser la mort et c'en est une
parce que bon on va l'avoir et il y à un
poète chinois chen françois cheng chi
une expression absolument admirable il
dit que la la mort donne un avenir à la
vie à la vie comme un domaine qu'on a et
la mort donne un avenir à la vie parce
que ils croient alarme et on va trouver
une croyance alarme qui survit au corps
dans toutes les religions
donc dans toutes les donnes
dans toutes les ethnies du monde on va
trouver sans moi et pour moi la poésie
c'est il ya un jeune homme qui me posait
la question où paroles et musiques
un jeune homme de 9 ans et il a dit me
chevillon moi j'ai 9 ans à quoi ça sert
la poésie réveille-toi tigan alors le
petit gars de 20 ans - s'est réveillé et
je lui ai répondu d'un voiture pour le
corps l'eau c'est précieux
eh ben pour l'en c'est la poésie et la
salle à absorber ça et le petit gant
après kim a fait savoir que jamais
répondu à sa question ils étaient
contents et après jour après j'ai
réfléchi à ce que j'avais dit et je me
suis demandé si j'aurai à le prouver
[Rires]
est ce qu'à un mode emo qui s'accroche à
vous comme une comme un phare ou commun
le mot liberté par exemple le mot
liberté je trouve très beau effrayant et
naïf on les humains le leu leu en joue
apparemment librement mais toujours
esclave de même et de tout ce qu'ils
sont avant d'obtenir la liberté et je
soupçonne les humains de prendre la
liberté comme une espèce de permission
de tout faire et de l'a400m
ce n'est pas ça ce n'est pas ça la
liberté la liberté d'être un humain
responsable ça déjà c'est de l'ouvragé
qu'est ce qu'on vous souhaite terminer
au ne me souhaitait pas le bonheur c'est
trop facile et j'en ai beaucoup
j'en ai beaucoup et je le je le sais
constamment en danger alors souhaité
mois la santé avec la santé il me semble
que j'arriverai à faire la chanson que
la grâce vient de tellement belle un
très beau et grand poème qui nous touche
en fait en réalité vous allez va nous
faire pleurer et à nous faire rire
parfois pour pouvoir mais dans beaucoup
d'émotion il importe oui mais là les
deux chez l'humain ben ouais mais vous
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire et pleurer
une chose qui me fait pleurer je ne
ferai rien pourquoi beaucoup de choses
qui me font rire mais je ne vis pas à
celui qui tombe sur une pelure de banane
me fait rire souvent la prétention la
prétention dont j'ai moi même souvent et
j'ai eu l'occasion de rire de moi-même
bon l'humour le véritable humour c'est
un vin du monde sur soi même la critique
deux fois même l'auto critique
intelligente est finie ça me fait rire
une chose qui me fait pleurer chaque
fois c'est une inscription sur une
pierre tombale qui a été inventé par un
homme est partial qui était un phaser
débit g qui a eu des écrivains des
épigrammes très célèbre mais il a dit un
jour à propos d'une petite fille de
quatre ans qui l'avait vue morte et
qu'il avait vu être inhumé il a dit à la
terre terre soit lui légère elle a si
peu pesé sur toi
je n'ai jamais cité ça sans avoir les
larmes aux yeux
c'est une grande beauté et en même temps
c'est très poétique très profond et
léger
c'est aussi
[Musique]
à